[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's Friday you know what that means
we start at conga line in Times Square
and pray we don't get stabbed
[Laughter]
leave it in so let's welcome tonight's
guests
her only threesome was with Smokey and
the Bandit a co-host of the bottom line
on Fox Business Dagan McDowell I checked
it with her
he knows what good TV is but decided to
do our show anyway TV writer and
producer Rob long
people love his shows because they can
catch up on Lost sleep comedian Joe
DeVito
it's when he flies one for him and one
for his belt my massive sidekick in the
NWA
[Applause]
oh we get to these news stories it's
Friday so let's do this
[Music]
red Silvers
tasty
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading them so if they
suck I get to kill anyone I want
a group of nude cyclists expose
themselves to children at the Seattle
Pride Parade
coincidentally it's the first time those
cyclists were exposed to exercise
and when asked if cycling in the buff
would be painful Lance Armstrong replied
my ball would be killing me
all right after the president was seen
with strap marks on his face the White
House confirmed that he wears a CPAP
mask for sleep apnea while the cleaning
staff also confirmed he suffers from
sleep apnea
three jokes in we got a poop joke
New York mayor Eric Adams is mandating
schools to offer two to five minutes of
mindful breathing exercises to students
every day yeah it turns out that the
average high school senior is only
breathing at a third grade level
Ah that's funny because it's true
Robert F Kennedy Jr released a video of
him Pumping Iron shirtless look at that
while he's hitting the weights others
will stick to the StairMaster
in a recent episode of The View instead
of saying beaches whoopee said
and if you work there that word would be
on the tip of your tongue too
a recent study found more manner being
diagnosed with eating disorders because
of porn
which makes sense since no one ever eats
the pizza that gets delivered
Liz Warren blasted the Supreme Court for
declaring affirmative action
unconstitutional she's been carrying a
grudge against white people ever since
she was exposed as one
let's hope she doesn't go on the war
path
oh yeah
don't take those blankets
[Laughter]
oh Danish Sailors were rescued after
their boat capsized from a collision
with a group of whales the Danish Coast
Guard warned other vessels to be on the
lookout by releasing this image
[Applause]
you're terrible
oh this insult conservatism
[Laughter]
was reported this week that the Earth's
axis has been shifting so it even things
out scientists are asking certain folks
to move slightly to the left
[Laughter]
just trying to do a whole hour
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
opens in theaters today it's kind of a
letdown the dial of Destiny turns out to
be the Life Alert button around Harrison
Ford's neck
Supreme Court just ruled that colleges
and universities could no longer take a
race into consideration for admission
[Applause]
instead they should admit students based
on which ones are most willing to have
sex with the professor
plus now huh a bunch of perverts
according to a new poll Kamala Harris
has the lowest approval rating of any VP
in history she's so unpopular her new
secret service code name is kilmead
so mean to Kamala
finally Dr fauci is joining The Faculty
at Georgetown University calling the
choice a no-brainer
coincidentally during the pandemic
that's what the country was calling him
[Applause]
some were obvious
but so was I
if you're flying for Independence Day
you better get down and pray and no
travel delays complete without excuses
from mayor Pete it's barely started in
already thousands of U.S airline
passengers who are Stranded by flight
cancellations and delays it's the worst
thing to happen to the airline industry
since the Hindenburg installed that wood
burning pizza oven
foreign
I don't think so but while Airlines and
other officials seem quick to blame bad
weather the real culprit seems to be
good old-fashioned bureaucracy stuff
like internal Communications and
lingering staff shortages from the
pandemic in fact U.S domestic Airline
capacity is still down 10 percent
compared to pre-pandemic rates and the
dip makes it harder to find new seats
for passengers whose original flights
have been canceled but one upside when
you're told that you can't get your
checked bags for days at least you'll
know Sam Brinton can't steal them
[Applause]
still fetching as ever
they'll fetch your luggage
nice
nice yeah nice thank you meanwhile in a
memo to staff earlier this week United
Airlines CEO Scott Kirby blamed
understaffing and lack of experience at
the FAA or fa
that's how you say it
which means some of the responsibility
for this mess has to fall on the U.S
Secretary of train wrecks
If This Guy's in charge much longer
we'll need to go back to covered wagons
but Buddha judge was quick to dismiss
the criticism by saying that weather was
still the major culprit figures that a
family with two dads would blame Mother
Nature
[Applause]
rob you sleep in airports often yeah
yeah you don't even have flights
scheduled I don't I don't have a home
that's what you do yes exactly you're
the most well-dressed hobo on the
Eastern board if you dress okay nobody
ever complains that you you know you
took a crap in the corner
the rich guy did it was like it's fine
he I'm sure he knows somebody yes yes
yes you still have the bindle on the
stick uh
not on a stick okay okay so do you think
this is overwrought do you think they're
blaming the right people
yeah and they're really everybody
everybody yeah yeah I actually do but I
think that we're two things one is the
constant rearrangement of the rules of
travel like everything is so miserable
like sometimes it's like take off your
shoes then it's like don't take off your
shoes yes and then you notice I think
they were now they go through the the
cabin and they close the shades or they
open the shades they close them to keep
it cool and then I get it right yeah
they open them when you land for some
reason that's a new rule they just
disappeared so there's all that but this
is I mean just to be serious for a
minute a lot of this is is about covid
we are going to be working out the we
did during covid for the next 10 years
we really did a number on ourselves or
actually the federal bureaucrat set a
number on us and not just travel but
schools you know we raised raised a
generation of kids to be basically Ted
Bundy yeah we're going to be paying the
price for 10 years and this is what this
is about and like we're all PR you know
all the bureaucrats trying to pretend
that it's the weather it's this it's
that no it's like we shot a hole through
our economy for two years for nothing
yeah exactly all right tires I go to you
because I think you are the only person
that's going to say what the other big
problem is and their big problem is
usually in Lululemon pants yep
see there's a couple sprinkled in the
audience
they start yelling
[Music]
yelling after tell their whole life
story to the front counter yes okay
we're we're all we're all delayed okay
yes
it's not a conspiracy theory okay not
because you're maggot tattoo on the
small of your back because the flight's
delay we want to blame Buddha Jazz which
is easy to do the man wore dress shoes
at a train wreck site so I get it but
it's
cheap ticket buying people's fault yeah
keep buying them spirits and the Jet
Blues not beautiful sweet Delta not
Delta Delta
Delta Hawaii whom I love better get my
ass home tonight because I will have a
different thing to say next time back on
but it's really it's people buying all
these cheap tickets online you get a 29
ticket yeah and then they bump yours for
someone who paid full price and it's a
conspiracy yeah your ass is cheap
there I said it he did he did Dagan when
I was a child and I think when you were
growing up in the South they did have
air travel but did they did they knock
from
I'm gonna get that promotion a lot
sooner than I thought
fire away no um no but I mean it was
different we paid you like always paid
full price for a ticket and you actually
work you know pants you know what I mean
it was a different world no I took the
bus
[Laughter]
see I wasn't far off and we are all soft
nobody remembers Greyhound yeah nobody
remembers having to wear a bandana over
your eyes so you don't have to look at
Donnie Dahmer sitting across the aisle
staring at your legs trying to decide
whether he's going to fry or fricassium
for supper or holding an empty Frito bag
over your nose trying to mask the smell
of the slosh and toilet in the back of
the bus
right I did things it's not the FAA it's
not the airlines it's the human beings
on the planes that make it so miserable
before you even push back from the gate
the jackass sitting next to you has his
shoes off and his damp socks off and has
managed to pull out his sweaty vittles
wrapped in some Saran wrapping his ain't
nothing before you're even in the air
yeah that's flying yeah
thank you
Joe as a comedian this is the uh the
generic wheelhouse uh oh boy flying yeah
what what's up with the airline industry
you know someone's written a lot on
Greyhound when they use the word vittles
I tell
uh I'm concerned about this United CEO
because they're having the worst
reaction to this and he was describing
their preparation and he said we're all
hands on deck that's what you say on a
boat yes okay so if they know there's
going to be water Landings maybe they
should let us know beforehand I don't
think on the Titanic they thought we got
to get this thing off the ground yeah
the flight situation is bad but I think
we're worried too much about the regular
passengers I think we're forgetting the
real victims and that's the drug mules
yes because well everybody wants to get
home for the holiday but imagine your
flight's delayed you're sitting in the
airport you've got two kilos of cocaine
shoved up your butt
you're nervous you're sweating it's
Fourth of July there's fireworks going
off it's very bad for the digestion
that's an interesting point how does a
drug mule handle like that sort of thing
like imagine being a drug mule and your
flight gets canceled yeah right your
flight gets canceled and it's like
you're coming from like I don't know
wherever who knows where it comes from
but let's just say Mexican let's say
Colorado Colorado
and they cancel your flight and you does
that mean you have to poop this stuff
out Do It All Over Again does that mean
you have to poop it out and then eat it
again yeah
[Applause]
where do I sign up
that's the only time you say let's see
what Spirit Air has to offer
like you got her like because you can't
keep it inside you hold on time out did
anyone here think of that did anyone
here say come on man what do you do when
you're running late do you re-eat the
drugs
no you worry about the bullet in your
head that's going to get for not being
there yes
drug mule Greg yes
you're in your in your Universe which I
I never want to visit in your universe
a drug mule is somebody who says you
know I won't do that yeah yeah that's
like they draw a line at that yeah
they'll do all
really I want my my meal voucher yeah I
think bigger problems number 10 maybe we
got number one through nine decided you
know what if drugs were legalized we
wouldn't need drug mule that's true
that's true yeah made you think didn't I
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else